carrying on from uh
my first uh
talk on uh energy and uh
well what nadeau said she had
this uh he uses a word a lot um
center circle
so
perhaps it's better if you listen to his
words and than mine
but
you know we
we start aikido
and most when we're beginners we panic
at most things
and it takes years
in my opinion
to uh
to get the technical so that
you don't keep saying oh can i do that
again can i do it again
and when you stop saying can i do it
again to your partner you usually find
that um
you know
you're still saying it to yourself that
wasn't very good that was very good
you seem to get less
good ones than you do
perhaps bad
ones a lot less
and um
but
nowadays
i've been thinking about how much people
don't have training time
when i first started uh
i just immersed myself in aikido day
after day after day year after year
after year
but now people have lives
i had a life as well but they say oh we
have a life to live so they're going to
do two sometimes three times a week
and
even though this is uh great
the time we we're at work or at home and
not on the mat we do have time where we
can
think
think about
the other side developing the other side
this is where i think the energy side
can come in
i've been teaching for the last few
years about
walking heavy
if you normally walk
then you're thinking and you're thinking
in the upper body
if you
um
just for a few steps
in the house or
you know wherever you are at work or in
the airport
wherever you are if you've got a few
moments to spare you can walk what i
call with heavy feet
this is a sort of grounding
so when he says center circle
he's talking about two things
and
when we first started aikido our
teachers always say
make yourself feel grounded
lower your center
you know build your center this world of
centering oneself
uh was
talked about a lot but rarely
expanded on
i remember
doing the same as i see students doing
now bouncing up and down you know people
try to sort of get
get into thailand or get into a
technique
and at the end of the technique we would
find ourselves bouncing
trying to push us
sort of mass downwards
absolute useless exercise that's what
the human brain
thinks because it doesn't know what else
to think
listening to
nadoshihan
being interviewed by patrick cassidy
another
hopefully well-known
top iwama
sensei
i think resides in switzerland now
he was talking about uh
a two
nado shihan and said
that he's made his own mark you know
he's he's different than the rest of the
crowd
and
you may never thought about it but
do you want to be
like a sausage factory student do you
want to come out the same as
all the rest
you know
doing your aikido tech techniques
technically
looking good being precise
well i'm one of these people and i don't
mean to sound like me me me
but among these people i've always felt
a loner
an individual
an oddball
whatever you
wish to put that tab on me
so i try to
do things differently and i try to
search
where i think
people are not talking about or not
doing
you see when i see most of the top
senses
japanese are all
from around the globe
we're all different
our aikido is shown differently
no two people
are the same
so
we're working on what our body frame
would do what our body mechanics would
do
we don't really see anybody doing those
senses aikido
the famous buddha film of when he was
around about the age of 50 the one with
so many ookies attacking him
he was very dynamic very powerful
and yet
30 years on he was still dynamic and
alive and buzzing you know his energy
even close to death seemed to be
far greater than
people half his age
so
i decided a long long time to go i
needed to look for more
so
in my out of hours out of map hours
i tried to think of not just
this
center that nado shihan talks about
but when he talks about the circle
it's
those oh you know
that may come into a circle or
those that um
are further out
on the mat
in the street wherever you may be
so
i started thinking that um
i should connect with the people
that are going to attack me
and what happens is we become very
individual
and we become
only
our only importance is for us to get the
technique correct
we don't really consider the
other person as far as the attack
they're going to
administer upon us
and what i've found is this
center circle
word of his
means that you need to connect
before they enter into your circle
you and the quicker you can connect with
them
it doesn't matter if they're
10 meters away
if you notice they're there
your mind
connects
and something inside my mind may not
work with you but something in my mind
connects with them
and
it says
i'm connected
you may doubt yourself
that's up to you i don't anymore doubt
myself if i think i look around and i
might connect with someone
then i'm connected they can even be
sitting in a lineup
and you look and you go connected
and you perhaps call them up for okay
if i just look and think oh he he
he's always good in a high fall for him
and aggie call him up
i've never worked like that i know a lot
of senses do but but i don't work like
that
i i just look along and i
connect
as soon as i connect i call them up
if it is a very technical
technique and i want to teach it and
show it clearly
then i may select hassan uk
the switch of connecting
wasn't asked upon or called upon by my
mind
because i'm going to do something
different
you could say ah but aren't you allowing
a weakness then if you don't connect
with them
perhaps i am i haven't thought about it
so
you may like to try this now
why we can't try it too early is
most of the time
you'll be standing there on the mat you
might have one partner
because you can see them with your eyes
you think that that's enough
trying to
bounce at the end of a technique to be
more grounded
one day when you find how to be grounded
without balancing
you will understand what i mean
you will just know that you're grounded
you won't need to question it you'll
just know it
most of the time we live in our upper
body
therefore we cannot be grounded but but
what after a few years you become
grounded naturally
when you become confident and i don't
mean egotistically but when you become
confident
you will find that um you can relax a
little more
not arrogantly but you relax a lot more
let's just say
for this instance
you know that you're going to say to the
person or the teacher said to the person
yokom anuchi shianagi
you know the technique
you're comfortable in within yourself
your own body and this is what
nadoshihan talks about
centering your centered
and then the circle center circle so you
make your center and that
circle whatever size this is going to be
for your attacker
um let's say they're five meters away
much further than your arm will reach so
it's outside of your physical circle
but it's not outside of your mind circle
because you've connected with them
so i'd like to try this from time to
time just say
no i can't connect with the person oh
yes i think i've connected with them
look around the class
oh i don't know why but i think i'd be
connected with this person try to grab
the mizzou case as soon as you can
the aikido may flow better it might just
work better
but keeping this parallel of connection
to me
is required if you ever want to do a
senses aikido
the more we become relaxed
we don't become
relaxed to the point where we're not
observing
this word called zanzin means awareness
we could call its ancient if you prefer
and we call it
awareness
but i'm talking about something a little
finer than this i'm talking about when
you can almost you taste it you know it
and you look along in my case being a
teacher i look along the row and i i go
i can connect with this person this
person and this person
i don't have to call them up
my mind is just telling me who i can
connect with a little bit like yin and
yang positive and negative
so once you've connected with the person
or more than one
what happens is
you've
you go to the next level
where you start to
keep that connection and their timing
when they raise their hand it's almost
as if they're raising
something with inside you in your body
you can feel the going out and going
down and i believe this is what i sense
he had
he was in her like um
awakened
enlightenment so he could
almost
not be there he would be like the ghost
of the other person
and whatever they'd done
he could blend with it because he'd got
the perfect timing of of those people
that
the ukis
and it didn't matter who attacked him he
could just quickly switch this
plug-in so where i'm telling you about
um oh i think i can connect with this
person this person this person
from then on you can go
why can't i connect with this person
what's
blocking me where's the block on this
anyway i hope you've enjoyed listening
to
this
stage of
how to work with your energy and
how to become more grounded
it will take
individuals
different years of progress and training
but you can start by walking heavy with
your feet and just notice the difference
between how you normally walk
and the heavy mass that you can make
under your feet
if you can notice that change then you
can start working on the other part of
the mind of connecting with others
and we'll continue this
journey together
further if you are interested
thank you